so I've named you by traditional
standards were incredibly successful in
the traditional world like you get an
MBA at Harvard you start working at
these big companies what made you decide
that you wanted to leave that world when
you're clearly on a trajectory to just
be successful that way it's a great
question it's one I sometimes ask my
students at 3m
no so the way to think about my career
so I actually have an undergrad in
chemistry which is a little bit kind of
random maybe but I started my career at
Procter and Gamble in brand management
and that a lot of it was just because
you know as a young person when you
don't really know what you're wanting to
do you sort of take the opportunities
that I kind of put in front of you and
see what that leads to and that has
really served me well and when I got to
Procter and Gamble they make things like
tide and pampers and crest there's lots
of different consumer things and what I
ended up I didn't even realize this
until I got into it but what I ended up
falling in love with is like consumer
psychology and they taught me how to
really see consumers problems and so not
as they say them but as they actually
experience them okay and so that
actually means like going into people's
homes and not just like listening to
what they're saying but how they're
actually their behaviors and things like
that that's not your job
yeah so as a brand manager your job is
for a different products for the product
that I worked on was actually in
pharmaceuticals so as drugs and I was
working on for example a packaging
project and you know you can have people
come in to do kind of focus groups and
stuff I thought but when you have them
come in and even bring they're like
little pill packs and stuff I thought
they'll say and you'll just ask them hey
how's the packaging working for you any
issues or things like that
you'll try to ask it in non-leading ways
but inevitably they're like oh no it's
you know it's fine you know I don't have
any issues with that and then we'd go to
in homes and there'd be fewer like maybe
just a couple of them but you now see
them kind of in the wild and you'd see
their homes and then just all these
different things I just still remember
this one time I walked into a home and I
saw the pill pack on the kitchen table
and there was a pair of scissors next to
it and the woman had just completely cut
the damn thing up and had set each of
the individual pill pack things into
like you know those Dale
kind of pill countersue so pill pack is
like the blister pack yeah the tinfoil
situation in some kind of cardboard
scissor cut some out puts it right
Sunday Monday Tuesday and I'm trying to
approximate that and I think the thing
is is that like obviously like child
resistant at all these types of things
but sometimes those can be challenging
on the other end if you're older and got
arthritis and things like that so the
insight there was here we're spending
all this money on this beautiful pill
pack with all this kind of stuff and
people are just ripping into it and
there's no delight there there's
friction all that kind of stuff and so
that was really powerful for me because
I realized the importance already of
talking to your users yeah but then also
like seeing their problems in real life
and not just taking them at face value
so that's where I think also like
surveys and things like that can be
limiting because people sometimes a
can't articulate what their problem is
in the way that they want to but
sometimes there's other emotions at war
like shame or embarrassment or things
like that insecurity huh and so that you
know I I started in pharmaceuticals I
then went and got my MBA I then went to
consulting so very very standard kind of
background but the thing that was
consistent was they were all consumer
companies um so even the consulting
worked on like grocery brands and
drugstore brands and then after that uh
you know good stint in consulting but
then went to adidas and did footwear and
apparel for a little while okay so again
the thread in my life has never been
necessarily the what but it's just a
really compelling human kind of problem
or like a really interesting brand
problem to kind of solve and so I went
to adidas and it's kind of funny it
started there in Boston and then my
husband and is asked to move to China so
we actually moved to China and he worked
there and I continued to work for adidas
in China and China from China and did
strategy there and that was just a
phenomenal experience yeah it's one of
my favorite quotes is the Steve Jobs
quote that says you can only connect the
dots looking backwards and I think even
though even though the arc appears very
traditional yeah I think the choices
that I've made with my career have been
a little
Orthodox but I think that's fine because
now as I'm in start-up world I'm
connecting these dots that I've kind of
come to me from the past but we lived in
China for a while and that's also where
I was pregnant with our first daughter
and so we decided to come back to Boston
to have her and embark on that journey
yeah and I think when we did we realized
this whole thing of like you know both
my husband and I are these people that
have loved our careers have moved around
um and you know loved all that when you
have a kid man that's a that is a life
change and they tell you but you really
don't understand it until you have a kid
and so we we decided we needed to get
closer to family my family lives up in
Vancouver Canada and so we made it as
close as Seattle um at the time my
husband went to Amazon and I went to
Starbucks still a very neat and tidy
kind of corporate story but I think at
that time to sort of circle back to your
question is I've always had this sort of
entrepreneurial kind of you know inkling
that I want wanted to start something my
parents were small business owners and
so I've always been around business and
entrepreneurship and I always figured at
some point I'd take my shot okay so most
people wouldn't think that once you have
a kid is when you're like going to take
that shot but for me it also is an
interesting thing because when you
become a parent and I can only obviously
speak as a mother but your calculus on
your time kind of changes yeah and so
for me what I wanted to do with my time
I knew I wasn't a stay-at-home mom but
if I was going to be away from my kids I
knew I wanted it to be something that I
personally felt a little bit more was
worthwhile of my time hmm just that I
want to continue with the story but I
have a question related to your story
what's your advice to people for moving
for their partner for a job like you're
both career minded people and you moved
all the way to China like what do you
tell other people I mean obviously like
a female founder that's an EVE it like
it's probably a classic example and
whether or not that's good or bad like
yeah so what do you say to people yeah I
think it's a great question I think it's
a really relevant question I think for
me and my relationship specifically my
husband and I have always looked at
ourselves as sort of equal
that way yeah and so even in this
instance though I was the trailing
spouse if you that's how it's called
there have been other instances that my
husband moved for example to Boston you
know I was doing school there and so
it's always been this idea of we have a
conversation and we say what is the net
good for the both of us and it isn't
always perfect Seattle is an example
where we managed to both end up moving
at the same time and find really
interesting jobs for both of our songs
but I think there are trade-offs right
so I think where one of us could have
probably accelerated faster or further
in either of our careers what we have
always said in the arc of our lives are
we making the choices are we doing the
things that is really true to us and I
think China that was actually a
particularly difficult one for me
because I just started like maybe seven
months prior yeah that job so if you
think about it from a resume standpoint
or anything like sort of rationale
that's not a good move to make for your
career but it's crazy that you could
even stay in the same company yeah so I
think that's also a testament to when
you work hard when you focus on doing
the work you buy your soluble self
options yeah so in that instance in
seven months I was able to prove myself
still yeah I was able to prove that I
was someone that you should give a
chance to to do something very different
in a different roles sure not part of
the plan but also I was prepared that if
that didn't work out I was prepared to
not perhaps be working while we were at
China and China and those are
conversation that you need to have and
be prepared to do and there can't be
lingering resentment like you have to
own your choices and so I think whether
it was me or my husband or for whatever
the reason is I think that's really
important I think it's also really
important as founders now you have to
own your choices
it is hard yeah and but you have a
choice every single day to do it or not
to do it right and so as long as you own
your choice I think that's an empowering
thing and so you're not thinking about
it through the lens of regrets or
what-ifs but you're thinking through no
this is my choice I made it now I'm
making the best of
and that opens up really cool doors but
I think managing careers with dual
working spouses I think a is not a topic
that's really talked about a ton but B I
think there are ways and I think you
know it doesn't necessarily always have
to be in the context of trade off but
there is this like you do have to have
the honest conversation about it yeah
and so what are your Pro tips for
managing two careers and kids yeah yeah
that's a lot of layers when it comes to
careers I think you know the
conversation for both of us has always
been we are we are people that get
engaged by ideas and we are not people
that can sort of do a job just because
it's rational and right and necessarily
pays well and I could you know there are
days that I wish I could be that person
you know even leaving my consulting job
I mean if I had stayed there and was a
partner in consulting like you know it
affords you really nice things and I'll
say this super honestly for those of us
that come from really somewhat more
humble backgrounds where money isn't
always a shirred thing I think that
drives us to go in and I know what
drives me yeah to never be in the
position to have to question money and
so I will say very honestly like that is
something that I struggle with now today
in starting a start-up because I've now
put myself in a position where I am not
financially sort of sound and where all
my previous choices have been at least
you know around like if not going all
for financial security but at least you
know in a comfortable place right that
is something that one needs to be talked
about because it isn't it's a reality
yeah you need to address it so from a
protip standpoint I mean it sounds sort
of silly but it is communication right
so I think people don't have hard
conversations often enough and deeply
enough and so it is saying hey this
makes me uncomfortable but we need to
talk about it and anytime you start
feeling something shifting into just
like a little bit of fester you know you
know talk about it mm-hmm
and when it comes to kids I think it's
the same kind of thing I've had founders
kind of ask me when's a good time to
have kids or it's like and you know the
same way that there's no good time to
start a start
there's no good time to have kids you'll
figure it out I think that's it's sort
of like like you know cop-out answer but
for me it is having a combination of
family and incredible nanny and a dance
like every single week it's a dance and
everyone needs to have like know their
spots and like all their roles and as
long as all that's working yeah it's
working okay one person sick somebody
has a business trip something else
happens and that throws it off and you
have to work to bring it back to neutral
but that's the constant fight and so now
is your husband still working in a
traditional like big company job no so
now he's also married to tech and to
startups as well and I think again
that's the same thing it's like you
could say that nope one person has to
you know hold the fork dancer is
thinking and it sounds very rational and
it sounds very reasonable I think the
thing is is that there's so many things
happening and to say tech is a silo or
tech is a vertical is sort of an
incomplete kind of statement tech is
everywhere now yeah and so for both of
us we were get so excited about the way
that tech is touching everything and so
for him yeah he's just equally as
excited and so he's doing his own thing
I'm also working on startups interesting
so before we get into the full poppy
story yeah what was it like working in
China
oh so this is in 2011 and we're in
Shanghai I don't know it's wild it's
it's it is hard in the sense of we have
moved around we're both Canadian we've
lived in the States for a number of
years over a decade and our work has
taken us all over the world but nothing
really prepared us for China I think
it's a fascinating culture a fascinating
country its history is really obviously
informs a lot of it's governed but
everything from language to you know
because management is are very difficult
and you know going to Hong Kong we're
like you know we've been to Hong Kong
maybe it's you know somewhat similar it
is mainland China is a is a thing of its
own and to live in Shanghai at the time
still felt like the wild wild west there
weren't a lot of expats and you know to
get around you still need to learn a
base amount of Mandarin so we picked up
Mandarin while we were there and the
most it's like a drug I will tell you
you start
working there and 40% growth rates feel
like sandbagging and if you can imagine
something like that and we're coming
from the US where 1 to 2% is like cool
we're growing 40% of san banking and so
it's everything is moving so fast you're
hiring people you're trying to do all
these things the world is changing
they're building buildings so quickly
there's an energy and a buzz in the air
yeah and I think to tell you the truth
having lived in Shanghai for that year
and then coming back to the US having
our kid and then coming back that truly
was also an impetus to want to get into
startups because it has this Drive of
things are happening in the world yeah
things are changing people are doing
exciting things and I need to be a part
of that and so coming off of living in
China working in footwear apparel which
is a really hot category at the time
just sort of showed both of us how we
could just get out there and take big
swings well it's not a coincidence that
big companies you know a big are like a
lot of you know celebrities in LA
whatever they come from certain places
because it's not only do the people that
want to work in that industry move there
but then you're surrounded by people
that are your peers and they're all
doing this stuff and you're like I got
to keep up at the very least and then
but what the beautiful thing is because
you come from other places yeah becomes
this amazing mosaic of different ideas
but we're speaking the same language
because we're trying to do the same
thing and that's all often what I love
about YC is because we come from very
different backgrounds we're doing very
different things solving very different
problems but we speak a common language
we're trying to do you know we're trying
to all talk to users we're all trying to
build product we're all trying to grow
companies and just like you know disrupt
archaic industries and so that
commonality gives us the common language
to talk we come from like fascinating
different backgrounds right like today
yeah oh we're at the female founders
conference yeah so Gustaf partner YC
asks you why did you start papi yeah so
maybe I can fill in the blank also in
the intervening time of working at my
traditional background and companies -
I'm starting poppy I actually started a
separate startup and so I have always
been passionate about
raising culturally curious kids so the
idea of you know we've moved around a
lot and if we can't live and move around
and live in all these different
countries then how do you bring that to
your kids and have them grow up to be
sort of globally savvy I think it's just
super important for the next generation
yeah
to to understand differences in
backgrounds and and be converse and and
not make it feel very threatening and
things like that so anyways a friend and
I had this idea and said why couldn't
this be this is also the era of
subscription boxes you know in 2012 or
so and so we thought oh honey how
they're like chapters within the past
five years ago and you know there are
there definitely are and so that was um
when you're seeing other folks doing it
you're like no no I could do this for
this vertical and so very similarly we
thought you know let's build
subscription boxes that have each month
a different culture so you know India
one a month China Japan and instead of
doing what we call sarees and samosas or
like you know sushi and samurais very
like stereotypical stuff yeah let's take
you into a market let's talk to you
about language and food the things that
really inform people and how they think
yeah and so we were really still am
super passionate about the topic but I
think the way that I approached it or we
approached it you know was very you know
very conventional I guess but we had
built a business plan we pulled market
numbers we had a story right because you
can find any numbers you want yeah um
and we focused more on product of what
we wanted to have in the box less what
we thought was gonna solve the problem
and so we built this and we thought we
were being scrappy and did it in about
six months and launched and started to
get going and as you know e-commerce is
hard customer acquisition cost can be
crazy the long-term value or LTV is not
necessarily there and so we learned that
the hard way this is a very niche market
even though people so this is where I
when people tell me oh I've been talking
about my idea and everyone loves that I
say be careful because everyone loves
you or you can sell an idea and there's
nothing no skin off their back to say no
that's a really great idea I can't
believe that no one's thought about it
we use that as validation and that was
sort of wrong
because the only real validation is
their money even with your friends like
oh absolutely I know that it's kind of
trite to say like your friends were are
gonna yes you but most of your friends
won't just give you money straight up so
you can actually ask your friends even
though even if they want to make you
happy this is also why I don't believe
in friends and family discounts yeah
and and it's not to say that you don't
maybe give them discounts or things like
that but just don't give it to them for
free right because that won't give you
the right signal for whether they're
actually valuing it so anyways the long
story short was that we spent about a
year and truthfully about $20,000 of
personal money bootstrapping and
ultimately came to the you know
realization that this was not a fundable
scalable company and instead of running
it as a small business and sort of like
a lifestyle business we were gonna shut
it down and that was a really hard thing
I think because I figured this was my go
had startups I had bought myself like a
year of time of not taking a salary
which was a hardship for me you had
already quit yes I put my job because I
said I think you know if we're gonna
believe yeah well we had been talking
about it on the side for about a year
right and we both had kids the funny
thing is maybe not so bad is that the
day that I gave notice that I was going
to quit my job I found out I was
pregnant with my second daughter so I
you know life choices in me know and I
think it is motivating I don't believe
in wasting another day if you don't
think that that's gonna serve you and so
for me though we now had two kids okay I
felt like I'd taken my shot at startups
and failed miserably if not like wholly
I learned so much but you know it still
feels like failure and so use up all my
money you stopped basically all the time
that I had said hey you know we can we
swing it you know with savings and stuff
- not for me to not make any money yeah
and but you know as you're as you're
failing or closing something else down
for me what was really important is I
needed to learn from a nice experience
and so I started talking to parents and
saying hey if this thing isn't really
necessary in your life and isn't really
important that what are some of the big
problems in your life that you face like
on a daily weekly standpoint
and the topic kept on coming back to
child care and I mean I knew that
because I lived the same thing like both
my husband and I work we had we didn't
have family that lived in town and there
was all these kind of random things that
would pop up you know nannies sick or
you know meetings running late and just
little things like that can just throw
off your complete week and add stress in
a marriage adds stress in the family all
the things like having kids is hard
enough that is just like a slap in the
face and so as I started to hear that I
realized that what people weren't
talking about was just needing a sitter
or nanny what they were missing was this
idea of their village hmm and so
everyone says it takes a village to
raise a child but you know all of us are
moving around for our careers for
education neighborhoods aren't that what
they used to be how many people know
their neighbors and such that you would
you know leave your children with them
and with all of that happening we don't
have any safety net as parents and so
that realization started to you know
kind of pop into my head and so even
though I don't have any childcare
experience like in that industry
I have no marketplace you know
background or anything like that
certainly no tech industry background
yeah I quickly saw how or at least
hypothesize how you might you know solve
that okay and so for me this is where my
chem degree kind of comes back and I
broke it down into like a nice like tidy
equation and so for me was that if a
village is a function of you know
someone that you trust is a fit for your
family from a like a values standpoint
and is there when you need them to be
could you break it down from technology
from a vetting mechanism a matching
algorithm and a scheduler uh-huh so
again it was this whole thing of like
let's just break it down continually and
then I figured okay well how would we
test that her and I could see an app
yeah but I can't build and so for a
little while I was you know stressed out
about that but then finally I was like
if I was gonna you know when for a lot
of founders I hear this you get obsessed
with an idea yeah literally can't get
already had it's you're sleeping you're
you're talking about it it's just in
your head all at a time and you're just
super distracted and finally I remember
my husband saying you just have to try
the damn thing out because it's like
either do it or don't do it
my friends who've been talking about
ideas for like five years do it or don't
do it yeah but you know you ought to
figure it out yeah and so finally I was
like well I don't know how I'm gonna do
this because I have no money left I have
no time well we should talk about that
right like so you try the Box startup it
doesn't work like did you honestly
consider just finding a job like what
was the moment that made you decide to
like double down yeah so truth be told I
was pursuing three and a good
risk-averse kind of way I had three
options option a was just returned to my
corporate career yeah I knew I could do
that he was good at it it didn't excite
me but I was like yeah you know I can
make some money and figure the next
thing out regroup the second thing was
you know what now I'm into startups I
don't have to start another startup I
could work in another startup that's
another way to go and do that yeah and
actually for some time I did actually go
there was a local travel startup with
nothing but engineers and I was the
first non-technical hire and even though
it was for you know only a couple of
months what that taught me was like I
now start like I met engineers for the
first time in like a really yeah
compelling way started to see how
software was built and that was really
cool but that was my second path because
I just figured that's what I'm gonna do
for some period of time and so I'm just
gonna go work in another startup lend my
passion and experience to another
startup which i think is a compelling
opportunity for a lot of different
people and then the third was just go at
it again and so I think the problem was
that even as I was thinking about the
more I guess rational or responsible
opportunities the idea just kept on
gaining steam and as I kept on thinking
about it I was like it doesn't matter I
don't have an I can't build an app I
could use SMS I could approximate it by
I could just go and find and vet you
know a couple of care givers and I can
go find these parents and just my
neighborhood doesn't have to be a big
fancy thing and honestly there are like
kind of vanity emotions that stuff by
that like people didn't even realize
that I had shut up shut down my first
startup so I didn't want to like make a
big hoopla about like you know starting
another one and so that was kind of good
because that gave me no expectations so
I literally this is where this whole
idea of the four we
test was I figured and you know my
husband's head like just go try it out
go figure it out I figured if I gave
myself the space of four weeks and the
whole point was by the now I'd started
reading some of PJ's essays I'd never
been in like you know hacker news and
all that kind of stuff not my background
but I started reading this stuff and I
was like just so interested about ideas
yeah and so I started reading this and
started watching how to start a startup
and this whole idea of can you just get
consistent weekly growth and can you
talk to users and build product and that
resonated back to my P&G days of like
doing that and that spoke to me so I
said I thought if I could find myself
for weeks I had like 200 bucks left in
my business okay great so I was like you
know what type forms paid like
Squarespace I can do a four-week trial
type form do signups and things like
that I can use Excel as a database I can
use Google Calendar as a scheduler and
SMS Triana connected all your personal
cell phone yep yeah people my personal
cell phone number and for the longest
time even to this day I will have like
old school parents still text my phone
it's wild oh no so I set it up as a four
week test and I still remember the day I
was like am I gonna actually do this
because it feels janky and it feels
scary again but I said I have to know
okay
so literally sent an email to 15 parents
and just said hey I've got these three
amazing people if you need them just
text this phone number and I gave them a
phone number as my phone number and that
day got our first booking and that week
I got four so that week was okay that's
my base if I've got for the next week
10% I need to get five okay
ended up getting six in the week after
even more and week after even more and
so I think more than the actual numbers
it was this idea of consistent growth
and then it feels different when you're
not pushing people to try your product
but people are people are pulling you to
give them more that felt very different
and so anyways that was the genesis of
poppy very almost accidental in some
ways but very driven by a specific need
I had a problem I needed to solve it I
figured I had a different hypothesis
than the other very crowded people in
like this very crowded in yeah
so someone from Twitter asked a question
494 asked they heard about your
four-week tests what are your
suggestions for someone who doesn't have
four weeks or works full-time job or say
as a college student gym whatever
generic busy person what are your tips
yes so the reason I love the and this is
just in retrospect the reason I like the
construct of a four week test is that
for a lot of people and especially
underrepresented founders and things
like that we face disproportionate
number of hurdles whether it's you have
kids or you have to care for aging
parents or you come from communities
that aren't don't have start up things
the point is you have to get to growth
and you're gonna have to double down to
prove that you deserve funding to be
around or whatever else just pressure
from your family like I know a lot of my
friends who like you know they have a
big fancy job somewhere and their
friends like why would you ever leave
that I've never had a 401k or whatever
stock options exactly it and so if you
use the construct of a four week test
inside of four weeks you can know
whether you have something or if you
don't and that way at least you know if
you do have something like I ended up
having that gives you the confidence it
gives you the the rationale to be able
to go tell your family or whoever you
tell yourself no no I can do this
there's something here and if there
isn't then there isn't at least you can
kind of either like regroup and learn or
whatever and you can decide your
commitment but you have to be focused
right so so say the question this person
seemingly is asking is like you don't
have four weeks of you know 40 hours a
week or whatever so how do you how do
you kind of like figure out the problem
figure out what to spend your time on if
yeah I'm just gonna yeah do it so I
would challenge people that you probably
have more time than you think and again
it is and I don't mean to be flippant
but you know at the time I think my
second daughter was maybe three or four
months old my older daughter was three
years old I was still in the process of
wrapping up my other startup so that's
just just to say there was a lot of
noise yeah but when you're when
something takes ahold of you and you
can't you have to do right by the idea
and I think about it I actually love
that I started startups as I started
because a start-up for me there's a lot
of Parenthood parallels you would do
anything for your kids you become a mama
bear and you don't care if you're afraid
you would do anything for your kids it
gives you a courage that you don't know
where it comes from in the same way for
my startup for my second startup because
I knew it had to exist not for me and
for any vanity reason but because I know
my users need it I know it does
something amazing in the world my job is
to make sure it doesn't die and so for
that I will do anything I will talk to
anyone I will hire like you know I will
you know I will do any work that it
takes to make sure my startup doesn't
die because it has to survive in the
world and so I think my point is is that
if it is the right idea it is the idea
that you're going to commit and I think
here's an important point too
is that it isn't about the starting
because if you're lucky and you actually
have something you're about to spend the
next five to ten years this is a big
misconception it's like all right I
should poppy be one it's like Congrats
you just started you just signed up the
next five to ten years of your life
devote to this mission so again yeah be
very sure you want to do that but if
that's my point is that if this is
something that you're meant to do that
you are committed to doing you will find
the time my second point when it relates
to college students that isn't to say
lots of young people don't or can to
start really great startups but don't
feel the pressure to start it
I have loved that I've had a very
disparate kind of kind of younger phase
if you will I've had the chance to go
and do lots of different things
experience the world all that kind of
stuff and all of that has been fodder
for building a more thoughtful more
interesting company and so if you're a
college student that just feels like you
want to start a startup but don't really
necessarily have that specific idea or
whatever else it is I would say go focus
on your studies like go take really cool
courses philosophy or like whatever else
it is go get interesting experiences
that will then serve you down the road
when you go meet your co-founder and you
actually have an idea and you want to go
do it I think it makes sense right
because like to what you were saying
before with you know the first startup
didn't work out something that's not
talked about is that a lot of the most
successful like you know monetarily it
will use that metric many of those
people just have a high batting average
they didn't shoot the ball one time and
so if they didn't never talk about the
dumb stuff they've worked on but like
they made all these stupid projects they
weren't precious about them yeah and I
was that I was that guy in college like
I was like all right I'm gonna come up
with this company idea this is it not
the average by any means so I'm Canadian
so I'm gonna use a hockey analogy but
you miss a hundred percent of the shots
that you don't take right Wayne Gretzky
Michael Scott there you go
and so I love that because it's
absolutely true yeah I I applied to I
see three times and so I think that's
also something that is misunderstood or
and kind of glossed over persistence
right if you think of the match applies
twice or more holy and um I think what
people misunderstand is that I think
somewhere in the glossiness of startups
and all that kind of stuff and no
founder I bet will tell you this but
most of us have had to persist through
tons of stuff
tons of investor rejection tons of
consumer rejection tons of just like
rejection yeah the point is you have to
have enough faith in self and faith and
vision to be able to see you through and
if the thing is the thing like for me YC
was the thing that I thought very
specifically was what I needed and
wanted to help me and so even when I was
rejected the first time I worked very
hard to make it be something that would
make it like increase my chances of
getting into YC the next time but I
guess the point by that time also was
even if I hadn't gone into YC by that
time I had a thriving company and I had
customers and I had all and so then I
was like screw I see if they don't like
what we like you know if they don't find
me just really gonna do this anyways
yeah but I think that was the right
thing I was not there with my first
startup I said I'm gonna need to get I
want to get into IC because of the
vanity badge and then I've made it or I
want to get funded by this VC because
blah but with Poppy again it puts
everything into the right context
because I wanted to get into IC because
I wanted to accelerate my company and
make it into something bigger and work
with the best minds in tech to help
improve and improve my probability of
success same thing with investors I have
now realized there are amazing people
that see our vision and their capital is
helping to fuel our growth and there's
other people that don't see it and in
fact
if you offer offered me money I wouldn't
want it because I need the people that
see our vision and our partners and
aren't just checks there certainly will
be times what you just need the money
yeah but I think especially for a
mission-driven company like mine you
have to have people that are body into
the mission to the timeline because
they're not always the same I'm not
building this to you know a quick flip
it kind of thing childcare is not that
category so you need the people that see
why you're doing this and believe in it
and therefore and then also write checks
so if you're I mean a lot of the people
that listen to the podcasts are
interested in pursuing the VC route so
we can just kind of assume that right so
say you're gonna build like a mission
back company like similar to yours
what what do you think about fundraising
like how do you go about that process
because it's true like your your numbers
aren't you know whatsapp numbers right
so how do you how do you find those
investors how do you convince them what
do you do yeah so I think I think
definitely it's hard for me to say what
factors kind of play into it but I
definitely know that in the early days
of me raising it was certainly hard
harder because on the surface it appears
a very crowded market it is hard for
anyone to understand why a person that's
coming off of a failed startup who
doesn't have a technical background you
know all the things like I if I was
fidgety I would say no too right
like there's no data to suggest that I'm
the one who's gonna make this thing go
yeah
but the beautiful thing that's also
where YC kind of came in was especially
what YC says is go prove it from your
users right if you go prove that you're
making something that people want and
that's why I was like you know what I
can do that
and so I went and I let the growth do
the talking and so there's one thing
that like you know around YC though we
say that growth solves all problems and
I love that one because if there's
nothing else I can do I go and try to
figure out growth growth helped me find
my eventual CTO and co-founder grows
helped me go and raise money if not
everyone saying yes the right people
started to say oh there must be
something here like what are those
people and then those people went and
talked to parents or the caregivers and
so the people who are in
interested in your mission as well you
will find them you just have to again so
Wayne Gretzky got to take more shots on
goal and it's a numbers game but the
point is is that again because I refuse
to let my company die I doubled down on
talking to even more people and making
connections so every person even if you
say no introduced me to three others and
that's sort of like this little kind of
breadcrumb trail that leads you to all
the craziest kind of places but
eventually you will find your people and
a couple will tip and that's the
momentum you need yeah absolutely so
let's do one more question from Twitter
yeah so Deepak chu Ghani asked how are
you measuring if your company has
reached product market fit I think
that's like what the billion dollar
question I think it's a tricky one um so
as best as I can tell I look at it a
couple of different ways okay um one I
think is from a retention point of view
right so if you've got product market
fit you have built something that is
working for people and they're coming
back to it they're using it they're
coming back to it they're not churning
it like some massive amount and so for
me product market fit has to do with
that stripping it down for me again I
think about it from a consumer
standpoint product market fit has to do
with the fact that you're solving their
problem you're solving their problem the
friction that they experienced in their
lives so well so completely that they
have no choice but to come to you right
and so I think a lot of those things
from like a lift or an uber and airbnb
people who completely in what five years
completely changed how people think
about a category like the people can't
even fathom going back in time yeah
that's what we're doing with childcare
and in a Parenthood and so my thought on
product market fit is how do we make
poppy something that parents just can't
even fathom being a parent without and
we're getting there and like we have
that here in Seattle because people will
talk about it we even had just a parent
yesterday and we have a text interface
so we talked to our user literally every
day and you know someone talking about
moving outside of our service areas and
making like just talking about how
that's that would make their lives just
so much worse to not have access to
poppy and so that is like goosebump
stuff but
that is also product market fit when you
have people that can't get enough of
what you're making and you're scrambling
to just keep up with that demand I think
in a lot of those types of terms okay
got you
I have a very random question then just
about parenting in general I saw this
interesting video about three parents
and one child they really it was like
this interesting relationship
yeah I'm just curious like do you have
thoughts on the future of parenting and
how it may be different than you know
the traditional traditional like model
that we used to I have I guess my most
of my thoughts are kind of almost come
back to the past where I love this idea
of I don't know if it's like communal
living but like multi-generational
living yeah my parents are Indian and
when I we would go back to India my
grandparents farm house just literally
had in the same farmhouse my three
uncles their families my grandparents
and you would go there and literally
like we wouldn't see my parents for like
weeks right because they'd be somewhere
like you know it is communal parenting
right yeah um my parents would watch out
for their kids my aunts and uncles be
watching out for us and I that struck me
in a very early age because I didn't
have that for the rest of my life when
we heard living at Canada and just the
ease the naturalness where Parenthood
isn't in crisis right it doesn't feel
like a crazy thing that you're like what
am I supposed to do with this kid yeah
um so how people do it in the future
whether it's you know multiple parents
or whatever it's more fluid for me
they're worried that it works is that my
nanny and her husband live in our house
right so like you know vineyards yeah so
they yes it's like a no parish kind of
situation you have like a separate kind
of an in-law apartment instead of
renting it out to somebody else we rent
it out to my nanny and her husband
that's great and the incredible thing is
and then when my parents come over and
if they're staying over they stay in our
attic kind of thing no but it feels a
while because this is what I feel like
it's meant to be the burden isn't
supposed to be all on my husband and I
right it allows us to have much-needed
breaks it allows my kids to get to know
their grandparents in a really
compelling in like natural way it allows
me to have mine
who feels like you know family be a part
of the family and for my kids for it to
be just very interchangeable and I think
that's really important I've read a lot
of research on I like the idea of
resilience and kids yeah I think that's
a really important quality that we don't
necessarily talk about a ton but there's
studies that say resilience is
correlated by or correlated with the
number of positive connections a child
has with people related or not and so
that's also what I think about when I
think of a poppy because we hear we have
these incredible care givers that go
into the lives of you know these
families and kids and they can be these
positive role models and we can build
you know lots of families have lots of
different you know situations going on
stresses or whatever else it is know
what you can never tell from the outside
but what I think about is that the more
you can put positive relationships
positive kind of role models in the
lives of children you give them a better
chance at being these resilient kind of
grown-ups so kind of following that line
what are your thoughts and and probably
advice around like parenting while being
a founder well like two founders now
like yeah what are your thoughts which
what do you tell other parents so I
think there's sort of two pieces for me
one is you have to be very specific
about boundaries and what that means for
me is there's certain days that I'm on
and I have to be a hundred percent
founder I can't think about you know it
sounds sort of harsh but I can't think
about my kids and like all the other
things that are on there will be days
that my husband's just like primary
parents so if a teacher has to reach out
or if there's PTA meetings or any of
those things or her nanny needs anything
my husband's on tap and there are other
days that I am and so that is just very
clear yeah I'm the evenings whose night
is it right to work late and there's
certain nights that'll be my night
certain nights will be my husband's
night and there are nights that my mom
will come over and stay over yeah and
that kind of gives up or nanny works
kind of late and so the point of that is
is that again it is very scripted there
are nights that we have - one of us is
traveling or somebody else has a meeting
or something that has to shift but we're
very specific about what those are and
the more that you make it routine
the less disruptive it is for our kids
yeah yeah and do you guys operate on the
the normal weekend schedule do you have
any like habits or traditions we're like
alright Sunday dinner or whatever it
might be we're like we're checking out
like turning off the phone so a couple
of them first of all I think you know
talking about the kids it's really
important because I want my kids to feel
that I am present and both of us are and
all that kind of stuff but at the same
time they're so there will be times that
I'm working from my home office and
they're like very welcome in and out of
the house but because my parents we
actually dropped them off for like
sleepovers that my parents have some
some weekends and that gives my husband
and I important time for us to be
ourselves connect we try to do this
tradition of like Saturday morning dates
instead of like evening night okay so
we'll go do yoga and have a coffee or
like a spin class and coffee and that is
something that we did when we dated or
went before we had kids the importance
of that is we remember our cells before
we became parents and that I think is
really important for parents in general
because I think I've heard this idea of
and I felt it too when I became a parent
of like you lose yourself you lose your
identity and that is almost more harmful
than anything else and so for us that's
really important that we square away
time for just him and I or just
ourselves to take care of ourselves and
then the last thing is um we do have
Sunday dinner okay hey you know III like
I'm a big believer of eating together
and that just like the whole cultural
aspect of that and so at the very least
we have Sunday dinner where we cook and
like my parents will come over and all
that kind of stuff and I think that's
also important for my kids to kind of
see yeah that's great
alright last question so we're at the
female founders conference I should
probably ask you what's your advice for
a female founder just getting started
you said it right there
so I think um I think there are so many
people out there and it can be female
founders it can be other
underrepresented kind of founders or
people with just like different
situations I think too often we have
really interesting ideas in our heads
and we just think about all the
obstacles that follow are in our way
yeah the reasons why we can't and that
stops us from starting and just having a
shot at it it's why I'm a big fan of
this whole like I made it up but like it
was just like a construct to fool my
mind about like before we
testers just give yourself something
small to get 200 paying users right
because I love the idea of like having a
hundred is a tangible target it isn't so
far off but it's pretty stretch paying
users to our previous point about know
they people vote with their dollars and
so breaking that toss down I find gives
people tangible reasons and a way to get
for them to get started but and
especially when it comes to women I find
that we are perfectionist this whole
idea of we don't want to mess up or if
we are going to start something it
should be perfect and so we like plan
ourselves to perfection which means we
also don't start and we have to get
really comfortable with it being messy
and complicated but the number one thing
is we have to start and we have to take
big swings they can't be you know I have
no idea I don't have a tech co-founder
I'm not technical how could I possibly I
had the exact same thoughts and if I had
those thoughts and I let them stop me I
wouldn't have started poppy so big
swings means like not doing something
like too easy really I think so this is
a controversial it can be a
controversial calm comment because if
your vision and if your mission is to do
something big then have it be as big as
possible yeah if you want to build a
nice smaller retail service business or
whatever else that is that's great but
let's not confuse that with startups
yeah let's not confuse that with high
growth venture backed ventures basically
startups I am a biggest supporter of
small businesses having been the
Donnelly daughter of two small business
owners but if we're talking about
startups and big swings that are going
to get angel and venture funded yeah
then we have to talk about big
disruptive technology and if that's the
case then we have to talk about all the
ways that that can be possible and if
we're not talking about that then we're
not were like you know dead in the water
before we even start
totally yeah I heard I think it was on
Tim Ferriss podcast with Chris Sacca and
he was talking about his investment
strategy and one of them was give
yourself an opportunity to get rich and
like all these people make these left
$10,000 bets and like you can never
really win that way in the same way like
if you have an idea like maybe it's a
small business that's all
you can crush it but like if you're
gonna take venture money and the max you
can do is ten million year or something
then like you're kind of you picked the
wrong game and I think in my motivation
in this certainly you know you know down
the road maybe there's the financial
aspect but for me it really is if we're
gonna do this certainly there's the 10
million version of what I could do
Richard yeah but if we're gonna do this
do it for the whole damn thing right
like if we're gonna do this and solve
this for parents everywhere let's solve
it for parents everywhere yeah and that
makes it the billion dollar idea right I
have no idea how we're gonna do it yet
but I definitely know how we're doing it
here in Seattle and how we're about to
do it in more cities across the country
but so solve the problem that's in front
of you worry about that first yeah and
just live to fight another day and I
think that's the biggest thing is that
you have to get started and just going
because if we don't then we're just
talking about it I think that's great
advice
alright thanks for coming in thank you
you